unser universum ist ein schwarzes loch
und zahlen auseinander fliegen dass
dieser ansicht ist der physiker nikodem
poplawski von der university of new
haven der urknall war demnach nichts
anderes als das explodieren des kerns
eines schwarzen loches wie was wo und
vor allem warum jetzt sind klick zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen zur
zeit sehen wir schwarze löcher ja als
etwas extrem außergewöhnliches an in
ihnen hört die normale physik auf und
alles wird extrem licht kann nicht mehr
aus ihnen entweichen und in ihrer mitte
wird eine singularität vermutet also ein
punkt ein unendlich kleiner punkt in dem
alles was das schwarze loch enthält
konzentriert ist nikotin pawlowski von
der university of new haven sagt alles
quatsch in der natur gibt es nichts
unendliches deshalb gibt es auch im
schwarzen loch im zentrum nichts
unendlich klein ist vielmehr ist es zwar
extrem klein aber letztlich konzentriert
sich dort alles auf einen endlich großen
punkt mit einer zwar minimalen aber eben
doch eine ausdehnung und dieser punkt
unterliegt kräften das schwarze loch
rotiert und diese rotation verhindert
auch die existenz einer singularität
schwarze löcher drehen sich extrem
schnell fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
der kern des schwarzen loches wäre
deshalb durch diese kräfte am kompletten
zusammensturz gehindert und auch
verändert durch die schnelle drehung und
der liegt er wahnsinnigen kräften er
verdrillt und dadurch quasi wird er wie
eine feder aufgespannt irgendwann sind
die kräfte so groß dass dieser kern
auseinander fliegt und sich diese kräfte
die dann die unglaubliche gravitation
des schwarzen loches überwinden ihre
bahn brechen und das schwarze loch
fliegt eben auseinander genau das trifft
auch auf das universum und auf den
urknall zu
genauso ist es quasi während des
urknalls passiert und diese pensions-
kräfte würden auch einige besonderheiten
des universums erklären so drehen sich
galaxien in der einnehmendes richtung er
rechts herum und in der anderen
himmelsrichtungen eher links herum und
aktions achsen von quasaren sind immer
im ganzen universum
parallel phänomene die mit einer art
verknüpfung zwischen allem zu erklären
sind und das wäre neben die kräfte die
auf den kern eines schwarzen loches
gewirkt hätten
das universum ist inzwischen 13 8
milliarden jahre als forschungsteams
rechnen damit dass bald die ersten
schwarzen löcher auf diese art und weise
explodieren würden es wird also extrem
spannend wie sich dann die ausgeworfene
materie verhält sind dort an ähnliche
überreste von fusions kräften zu finden
spricht einiges dafür dass das vermutete
multiversum genauso wie unser universum
aus unzähligen schwarzen löchern besteht
die universen gebären und auch
vielleicht wieder verstehen wenn es neue
erkenntnisse dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier wenn ihr kein video dazu
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
aber aufs auge vergesst nicht den genau
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter also
hiermit es gibt keine wirklichkeit
multiversum da gibt es noch mehr infos
zum multiversum absolut mein blowing
also darauf ab klicken und nicht
verpassen
ansonsten bis zum nächsten mal bis dann
bleib dran